Bye
five ingredients that I always have on
hand you now as a salt and pepper deal
and then,
you know,
whereas that,
these days I have a lot of blue hill
farm is really gung ho into this milk
deal.
So like we have now nine cows that were
milking,
so I generally always have milk on hand.
This is a new thing but unpasteurized
beautiful milk and we're experimenting
with all this stuff with that.
So,
you know,
I would say three,
four and five is about something of
milk,
like either raw milk or,
or,
or butter which we're making from the
milk or ricotta cheese or Mozzarella
cheese.
Somebody that's coming out of the dairy
and that's coming from the land,
you know,
and that,
that,
that is exciting that,
you know,
we're using this the,
where I began.
Uh,
and we're,
we're,
we're expanding on it.
And uh,
and now in the kitchen,
I'm making things out of it.
That's it.
There is nothing more pleasurable to me
than,
than having that kind of connection.
And I hope to share that with,
with one Pico.